the two come 3,000 is at home in ports
all over the world today one is
unloading iron ore in the port of
boone's bottle
Ignatz cleco has been behind these
levers since 6am today the 28 year old
is happy with his job as almost human
there are certainly worse places to work
through here on the river elbe otherwise
I wouldn't do it so not father Tania in
Burma when we have the hook on this
crane we can hoist a hundred and twenty
tons and unload them an object weighs
120 tons that's huge not everyone does
that eyes or star here when Ignatz clock
oh isn't unloading iron ore from chila
he uses the two con to lift coal
soybeans containers or parts of wind
turbines
the crane is versatile
port cranes like this one have been
built in a bus Valda in the state of
Brandenburg for about 100 years even
during East German times ibas valdakk
rains had a good reputation Hines
Schultz has been working here for almost
50 years the cranes he helped build were
sold primarily in Warsaw Pact countries
but some went to capitalist countries
even West Germany bought cranes in Eva's
Valda yah mule a few thousand will built
more than 4,000 cranes and then you have
to sell them somewhere in the world now
cranes stand in the Eastern European
countries they stand in South America
trains were built ER in Asia everywhere
whether it's Iran or Iraq or Chile and
I'm proud of it yeah I'm proud okay
stood the next arts unlike many East
German companies the crane builders in
Eva's Valda survived the collapse of
communism but they had help a company
from Leipzig and another crane building
company from West Germany merged with
them to become what is now called the
canyon joining the employees from the
former East Germany were colleagues from
the West like Wolfgang Meza whose
responsibility is sales and distribution
via harmony let's in recent years we've
invested massively in our distribution
structure we've opened an office in Rio
de Janeiro we have an office in the
United States we strengthened our
offices in Western Europe and doubled
our staff and our st. Petersburg office
what you possess all to spill horse and
some pitas papadopoulos cranes are an
international business it's useful that
many of the original staff and ibas vada
learned Russian employees from the West
handle the english-speaking world but
the company is more focused on its
common future than on the differences
between east and west the Odin young
people no longer distinguish between
east and west when you mentioned
something about the time before the
Berlin Wall fell they say I was just a
child that's history yeah we really are
growing together suzama
it's been a long journey from an East
German company to a giant corporation
that builds the world's biggest port
cranes